on this week's show should I buy
property through a limited company in
the news who should piece that jury the
buyer or the seller and we're gonna be
answering all your property related
questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
EADS I'm Alistair Cunningham and welcome
to the property investors podcast what a
great show we'll be talking about
whether or not you should buy property
in your own name or for a limited
company and on the news we're gonna be
looking at stamp duty this talk of the
moment as I'm switching it from the
buyer to the seller so I'm gonna be
delving into that as well you just got
back literally just got back from
Cypress man was like this morning it was
like six bucks mono so today I have
collected the keys for my new apartment
[Music]
I've never been to Cypress well I've
been a few times actually but this
wasn't really a holiday it was more of a
work thing so it's just a speaking a
training event so okay you enjoy it it
was alright I had a little bit of time
either side so I'm like half a day in a
day love other side it was nice I pulled
a little yesterday so it's cool
brilliant so you moved in we've both
moved we're here in London so we've
moved this is that this is one of the
one of the rooms in our new offices yeah
which is cool it's cool I actually
yesterday was my first because I had the
week off to move house everything last
week so yesterday was the first day of
me coming back into the office how was
the commute the commute was it was the
Train of 23 minutes right which is
pretty good I do have a mile either side
of the train so at the moment I'm just
walking that okay which means there's no
four miles walking a day it's good it's
good but it's quite long yeah I quite
like you for listening to my audiobooks
you know it takes me like an hour to get
in a 20-minute walk 23 minutes rain 20
minute walk so it's good for that but
I've just bought one of those folding
bikes
like a little clown makes a little wand
you fold up
what's our clown by giver is the one
that's that eulogy pull a string Network
sold online so how much was that no two
hundred fifty quid whole like mega money
no no boy you wouldn't want to start
with because I thought if you know you
know when you're on the tree and in some
no bed gets on my bike about this big
does it really fault up to the size of
the wheel just like 20 inches folds or
it all folds around the waist why didn't
the way of it all folds around the wheel
so yeah it's pretty small because I
realized because I've obviously got a
bike yeah don't use it but I've got a
bike but you're not allowed to take the
train on the bike between 7 and 10 yeah
so I wouldn't been able to take it on
anyway so you can but you can bring this
one on this one you can it's just a
folding bike you can pretty much just
like a carry case and oh really yeah
you're gonna be alright putting it
together I can oh you're not very very
have paid them to do but even like
lifting it up and put it down is it
going to command trying to put a push
tear down oh when I go when I go to the
shop on me good pretty good pretty good
Communion and the house my house is
awesome yeah but you've got worse always
yours you use a beacon tree no Packers
field because be country I've never
heard of be control wait to show that or
no I went through that beacon peon on
underground other day anyway declan's
field is spelt
Beaconsfield yeah um are you getting
mixed up okay um but um so yeah course
like how many or how many bedrooms six
okay nice very nice
big garden yeah very nice house I look
forward to seeing your house yeah well
it's an apartment and so I've just got
Keith's morning to bed apartment in
Kilburn which is literally literally
come out the door ten yards you're an
underground station and it's only four
or five stops to where I need to be for
work so so good it's really good and
underground carpark
so I've got a little gated to drive up
the gate open
I'll go you go in and mine's a private
guy okay so for me just for you not fit
well and my family okay remains is from
Maine and a few other families have you
got swimming pool no I have is it just
for you
no well I could go to the local Leisure
Centre remains it's downstairs literally
I go to the elevator go to 0m label
minus 1 and here I've got a full gym and
swimming pool and it's actually a nice
swimming pool I thought it'd be a bit
like ropey do you know when you go to
one these rubbish hotels and it's got
like a mediocre or take swim pool it's a
bit raw P I thought I'd be at that but
you rose I mean like grimy yeah grimy
and during a bit like you wouldn't
actual wanna go in it it'd be you've got
really nice high-end apartments it's
nice it's actually really nice that you
it's clean there's some din there walks
there's somebody walks in there every
day just keep keeping it clean and
keeping it presentable now and it's cool
it's really nice and the waters heated
as well so it's not freezing cold water
so it's good so yeah I'll be making use
of that beautiful man well it's exciting
laughter I look forward seeing yours and
you can look forward to sharing your
mind absolutely I was officially made
okay so on this week's show first thing
was buying a property should you buy so
you buy a limited company like I know I
know that you'll get this I get it all
the time especially at the property
investors crash course yeah people come
over to me problem is it for us to just
give a blanket answer is very it's not
it's not really possible because we you
need to take into consideration their
personal tax affairs well the thing is
it's quite a complicated question it's
not a straight yes you should know you
should so dig into explaining that
obvious what we're gonna be doing on the
show today so hopefully if you're
watching this make notes and we'll go
through the pros the constant that's the
thing that it's a pros and cons
yeah it's not a a an obvious necessarily
answer but fundamentally I think we need
to make it very clear from the offset
that this is not tax advice they need to
meet cliff not offset that you do need
to speak to an individual tax advisor
about your personal circumstances this
is just an overview for the pros and
cons generic advice
generic advice yeah okay cool so let's
start off I suppose the first thing
you've got to take into account is
what kind of property investment are you
planning on doing so there's sort of two
types really you've you've got buying to
make money out of the rent right okay
you know you normally normal yeah like
you know HMO or for service
accommodation or whatever it is yeah and
then you got buying it to flip by
refurbish refinance so if you're doing
boffo but refinance buying to flip
buying to add value and then sell on
yeah it pretty much always make sense to
buying a limited company okay
reason being is that corporation tax
which you all pay any property makes
corporation tax is usually lower there
for you than if you're paying income tax
so if you buy it in your own name you're
gonna pay income tax on X Y for a
company with corporation tax so right
now as of this filming here are your
rates corporation tax is 19% yep
basic income tax so like up to 50 grand
if you're if you're earning less than 50
where's 20 percent yeah so even if
you're a basic income tax payer it's
still better to buy for a company
however this is where the key comes in
for people on alastair who is on a
higher rate tax 50 250 grams 40% yeah
and 150 plus 45% so suddenly if you're
earning decent money
so the corporation tax is at nineteen
percent across the board all the way up
mmm-hmm I knew it was bite why do you
clarify that just for the listeners yeah
and they're under viewers yeah so 19
percent across the board and you are
yeah so really if you're buying to flip
I probably would say normally again not
at ice advise but normally gonna buy
through a limited company right now that
aside most property investors are not
doing that yeah most investors are
buying to keep yeah so let's not look at
the pros and cons from my opinion there
are two main pros applying through a
limited company it's a both attacks
related so the first one is kind of
similar to what we just said about
corporation tax versus income tax
corporation tax is obviously less yeah
so if you if you buy through a limited
company the rental income that you earn
is classed as profit to the
company yeah that's corporate so you pay
corporation tax on it not as profit to
you as an individual which is income tax
so let's say let's see what house and
you were earning 500 quid a month rent
from that house you'd be paying that at
a lower a lower rate if you run for a
company that if you were adding on to
your salary and paying as income tax so
it kind of makes sense straightaway as
the first reason less tax now here's the
real kicker and this is the thing that
really makes a big difference this has
not fully come in yet but this comes in
in two thousand two thousand twenty I
believe so it's coming in soon it's
being staged in and your this is the
main reason that we both yeah invest
really meet companies and that is this
you can't claim the interest on the
mortgage so most mortgages it's mostly a
lot of its interest isn't it hundred
yeah most of it especially because most
people are doing problem based and I
used an interest on the mortgages as
well so okay so give us an example of
how this would affect and they explain
weeks by hour late because I've been
doing a lot of talking was your meter
and so okay one of my properties for
instance my mortgage payments are 253
pounds yeah but it's purely interest so
I wouldn't be able to reclaim that 253
pounds if I'm buying in my personal name
now this is crazy because this is nuts
right let's say your your mortgage
payments are for in Japan a month yeah
and your rent is 450 pound a month yeah
so how much profit you make it yeah
fifty fifty quid so you should pay tax
on the fifty quid yeah but you can't do
you you can't claim the tax back on the
on the on the interest rate but it's not
counted as a tax expense and they should
do it for a limited company so it means
that you're only fifty quid but you're
paying 20% tax so you're paying eighty
pound on tax oh you're actually paying
out eighty quid more you paying thirty
quid more and that's if you're on twenty
percent tax if your higher rate tax
you're paying like one hundred and sixty
quid see only fifty quid paying one
hundred six-packs yeah so if you're
earning fifty quid you
yeah one you repay an 80-pound so you
actually 30-pound worse off every month
and that isn't our 20% that's the 20%
all right if you're a 40% tax payer
that's a lot or about your scene this is
why you're seeing landlords that I've
got old school and those have bought
everything in their personal names our
sale and their portfolio there's
suddenly screwed because there's some
for making a small profit on each make a
massive loss and losing and actually
having to put money into it every month
I know one landlord it's selling 23
properties because he's the new tax
changes yeah because he says I'm not I'm
not having it and for him to convert the
properties from a limited from our
personal name into a limited company is
not efficient it's not financially
viable I don't know the process I get
that's the question I get asked a lot
and people have bought properties in the
personal names then I want to flip them
to a limited company do pretty I think
you've pretty much got a sell it to you
I was gonna say because you're sailing
it's a lot to take place at some point
hasn't it so that you've got stamp duty
you've got tax benefits as tax
implications as well because obviously
if you're sailing it and you're making a
profit there's tax it's just a minefield
that's why we see you need to speak to
proper accounting here's the thing
though right that is terrible news that
only applies if you're oh you own the
property as an individual yeah so if you
own the property as a limited company
mm-hmm then you can put the interest in
yeah but you can't get mortgage for a
new limited company's name you can't you
can that's being sarcastic
people think that law people think that
it's very difficult to get a mortgage as
a new limited company set up there
aren't people think that you as a new
limited company you cannot get a
mortgage no I'm not saying you can get
it the same Bay but there is companies
out there will do it if you act as a
personal guarantor well you've pretty
much got it yeah yeah you're free much
got it but if you you can so you can do
like a fresh limited company with no
trade in history as long as you account
or basically what it is it's really a
personal mortgage with a wrap top as a
limited company mortgage so that you you
can so you can get these tax benefit yes
so that these the better big - right
cheaper tax right yeah and you can claim
the interest on the mortgage as a taxi
expense now that could be deal-breaker
massive so you look at that you're
thinking well why are they saying it
depends yeah because it's a freaking
no-brainer you're gonna buy free limits
company there are the advantages let me
tell you the disadvantages and there are
three okay okay in my opinion yeah whose
opinion my okay not tax advice my
opinion number one the mortgage rates
are a bit higher yeah yeah so are
looking at it on average you look at
about 1% more yeah so if it's a three
percent or three and a half percent for
a for an individual mortgage you're
looking at four four and a half right
which means on 100,000 pound mortgage
let's say you paying 3% an individual
that'd be 135 pound a month yeah
whereas for a limited company you're
looking at about hundred eight one
panama fries so the repayment so it's
not mega but it is a little bit higher
that's the first disadvantage
disadvantage number two go on just
quickly before you go back yeah
the the mortgages they're not it's much
easier to get a mortgage in a personal
name and it isn't a little company not
say it's not it's not impossible it's
just much it's easier that the skorpa
lenders is much bigger for limited for
personal as opposed to limited so it's
less it's less selling used a bit yeah
it used to be I agree with you you are
correct but it used to be like let's say
you know yeah yeah it's like it's kind
of gone like that so yeah it is it is
easier than it used to be I think it's
going more and more that way as well
yeah because more and more people
nowadays by for limited company tax
reasons so in mortgage and lenders have
opened up yet to doing more limited
compliant demand isn't it amounts right
so but you are correct it is a bit
though there are more lenders doing
individually is a disadvantage that yeah
it does take a little bit longer to get
a limb to limb to come due mortgage yeah
number two now hey here's a big one as
well because this is where this is a
where it very much comes to the what we
talked about the it depends it very much
depends on what you want to do with the
money yeah right because this is
something I've come up against if let's
say you buy for a limited company and
your plan is to save the money and then
buy another property
brilliant yeah bro makes sense if you're
trying to create a passive income to
live off and it's your only source of
income
yeah then you get taxed twice if you get
taxed a 19% on the corporation tax but
then to get the hold of the money you've
got to take it out dividend or income
tax or whatever any get taxed again so
what you want to do with that money is a
massive factor on whether you should buy
as an individual or buy for a limited
company because you potentially could be
getting taxed twice yeah so something to
bear in mind
and the final disadvantage just another
small one that's the main one really
yeah that's yeah number three you're
gonna you're gonna have to do company
accounts you have to get you know you
have to serve a limited company it's
very easy but your web set of limits
company have to pay for an accountant
and that's just part of the running cost
mean you compare you can get an
accountant or do your books like seven
hundred pound a year or something it's
not that expensive yeah and if it's
gonna save your money it's definitely
well worth it yeah so the bottom line it
does very much depend yeah
bottom line speak top property tax
expert and lay your cards out on the
table this is your situation what a be
honest what you want to do with the
money as well because you cannot just
sort of willy-nilly take money at the
limited company just for your living
expenses no you can no no you can't so
it does very much depend on what you
want to do if you plan to live off that
let's say you plan to live off the money
and it's your only source of income
which means you get the first twelve and
a half thousand man tax for anyway yeah
there's your own source of income and
you only want to buy our two properties
then buyers individual yeah because
you're not want to but if you're owning
50 grand a year and you want to build a
large portfolio and you want to put that
money into other properties yeah then
it's a no-brainer to buy for a company
yeah
so it does depend a little bit on your
situation personally for me I mean I run
over businesses I don't just make money
as it so it just makes sense to buy for
a limited company I would be crazy not
to yeah I know you buy for a limited
company as well
my usual rule
thumb is it is better to buy for a
limited company but in my head yeah I
don't know what you think I really have
for me it's a no-brainer when everyone
says to me what helped you to do it I
can't give them advice on their
situation but I also look I want to do
everything I do what we know there was a
company of things so what questions
should they be asking themselves when
they what do they want to use the money
for yeah that's the first thing how is
it gonna affect their current personal
taxes because obviously you've got to
differentiate from personal tax and
business tax yeah there's to it they're
two very different things and so you
need to know how you bad problems gonna
affect your personal tax affairs and
this is this where you have to lay your
cards out on the table with a proper
accountant speak to them tell them
exactly what you plan to do exactly what
you plan to do with the money you know
current situation your current income
your current assets and see what's best
for you how much how much do you want to
borrow yeah uh what are you earning
currently yeah and how much you want to
take out what isn't how well yeah
if you only want a little bit out of it
that's different if you want all of it
mm-hm
like it depends I person would reinvest
it I would take as minimal as possible
and just reinvest reinvest well that's
what we teach isn't it we teach to
anything you so you save 10% those raise
a question law that if you're reinvest
and reinvest and reinvesting that does
come a point where you're gonna want
that money so that I what's the point
then there's gonna come a point where
you've got you can have all the assets
in the world and they're mass it's a
creating cash flow but then at some
point what you can do with all that
you're gonna pass it down the line to
your children or and leave it as
inheritance or what you can do it at
some point it has to be realized and it
has to be on that inheritance as well
that's a whole main fluid inheritance it
isn't my if I'm not going to go into it
but what I will tell you which is what
I've been told it for my tax advisor is
that you want to own it if you want to
pass it on yeah there are lots of clever
things you can do this.and limited
company that you can't do if you own it
yourself
so there's another small advantage right
there to inheritance yeah because you
want to what why would you I mean if you
if you for me the moment that you go
that's
off now I'm gonna take the money you've
given up on yourself
yeah no not necessarily because no no no
no no just take a high-wage take a wage
out of it and carry on investor okay but
the wage this is what I mean you're
gonna want to take some money out of it
of course so that horses depends on the
tax but the but if you manage such a big
portfolio that you don't care about tax
ah you know I agree with you I agree
good you shouldn't let tax put you off
doing anything because the worried worst
thing I ever hear you unrated that they
want to get back edge to do what you're
holding back your business yeah you
idiot you [ __ ] so I believe that Oh
Nick you [ __ ] annoys me more than how
small mind is that yeah I would rather
go massive and just hit the thresholds
be VAT registered hey what you ought
it's not difficult cuz if you're arenít
you can peer yeah right
but don't get me started about that
thing its arguments I have with people
all the time I just I can't deal with
them I can't deal with it the the small
mind and no small minded and the the the
lack of desire it's just crazy
beggars belief from her hostess I mean
yeah I mean sure but if you do something
creative to keep then cool but don't sit
there and go I need to learn because
that may seem it was it now eighty grand
eighty four thousand eighty four
thousand last last time I heard was evil
right so what you're doing is you're
saying I want to grow a business that's
never gonna believe the reality is but
think about if you've got businesses
that's turning over eighty four grand
it's very likely you're not gonna be
making much money no because when you
factor in course you certainly won't be
able to have staff know just is just
yeah you're an idiot if you see that I'm
for I'm sorry you are
I know I genuinely know some day who
only works three days a week so he
doesn't have to become bat registered
and beg you only wants to do three days
a week he wants to do more he wants to
add more money but he's so scared I mean
VAT registered he doesn't want
but I'm like you do know you charge that
baton and he's it yeah but then
customers won't like it and then they
might leave me and all that sort of
stuff and I'm like well good give it
then you can't grow you can glass
another problem the customers might
leave but you'll get better ones that
will pay your money anyway it's more -
let's move on right okay so it's now
time for this
[Music]
so in the news chancellor Sajid Javid
has denied a report that he was
considering shifting responsibility for
tax duty from the bias to the sellers so
there was a lot at all yeah it's it's
switching what do you what do you think
a good idea so currently obviously if
you're buying the property one of the
course so stamp juhi if it's an eligible
property now i know why they're doing it
they're trying to make it so the costs
are lower for people to buy houses
because then that would stimulate the
the markets that would that would mean
people it makes it more affordable
people to move house especially when you
talk about some of the higher-end houses
the stamp user name are very like a
large sum of money and so maybe that's
one way they're thinking of trying to
stimulate let's just put the price up
maybe but with that i don't know if i
would work or not because obviously if
the price has gone up and it's not
valued at that taking that's gonna be
undervalued isn't it so the content the
mortgage valuation but i think moving on
to the sale are I just think also did
you put the prices up and then that come
me because well they can if they all do
it if everyone was the prices up yeah
which I would if I was selling a house
suddenly I'll be thinking but suppose
they probably don't mind that and they
get more stamp do so so I actually
probably if I put the houses here that's
a good point actually
all the houses went up and then but all
the Stampeders will go up so it's just
so and fundamentally who gets more money
the government yeah the government are
not idiots right they probably realize
that's what will happen then the sales
will put the price they will put the
price up to accommodate this land you
they've got to then pay but ultimately
if they put the price up and it goes
across a different bracket and in the
end they get more stamp jury and I don't
know I'm not sure if I agree with it or
not if I was a sailor of a house
you're not the wire we're buyers aren't
we we're buyers I'm more we are sellers
but we're more buy
I'm from from a bias point of view it's
very good because it's less cost and
moving house let's close up it just goes
into mortgage just wasn't the mortgage
so isn't that so for a property investor
point of view is probably quite good
yeah less cash in your RI would be
better because obviously less cash in
and from a seller point of view
obviously they're not going to be overly
happy about it but but most people let's
face it the government are just
constantly trying to batter us with
something of overtax something so you
sell something you make a bit profit
they wouldn't charge you even more money
yeah what's the average is that we I
don't know how much is it four or five
thousand pound for it babies I know but
like could be a hundred grand good news
yeah yeah okay on a two hundred thousand
pound house what's the summary yeah if
you don't mind I've gone out actually
have yeah may have deleted its on my old
form let me just double-check I did have
an app that told me because obviously it
depends on it depends on things such as
if it's your first second or third home
yeah stamp duty tab tab layer there's
one on the so the website called stamp
duty calculator all UK yeah I don't know
so they should stick to the grand
oops two million that's a bit much
calculates 1500 quid okay so no no
clickers after you first if it's your
second home the percentages change 200
grand I did think that seemed a bit low
seven thousand five so that right so
seven and a half grand for an average
property price in the UK which is what
you is going to be shifted to the sale
or if they've got the government have
their way that's a big saving for
somebody looking to buy a house isn't it
mmm-hmm because if you're looking to buy
a house work me for an investment or as
are a residential it's a big it's a big
investments a big purchase and if you
can reduce out a little bit then happy
it is your first time buyer it's free
yeah happy days first time buyer free
happy days but I don't know I from a
seller point of view it's brilliant it's
from a buyer point views Brewin from
sell point view not very good but we're
by us so you were
because then you wouldn't it if you sell
it to a to a property investor was it
higher than if you set it to a
first-time buyer how would that work or
if that's a good point you know if the
Sailor has to pay it they may prefer
first-time buyers or people that
wouldn't got one house that means they
may then discriminate against people
that are investors of what multiple
houses although we're reading into this
they've just announced it's not going to
happen so it's kind of a pointless
debate no it's not it's still
interesting I think it's interesting do
you think is still interesting comment
below very interesting I mean it's
really interested now it's just it's not
changing it staying as it is don't worry
about it sorry Nick I'll bang the table
joint come on you ever where angry angry
it's just another stick the government
can smack somebody with into it so a bit
like a TV streamer alia yeah
true story you know in our customer
service department upstairs doesn't
matter it's now time that's interesting
okay so it's now time for our questions
and answers if you want to ask us a
question then either drop a comment in
the YouTube video and we'll answer the
ones that we can or if you join the
property investors with Samuel EADS
Facebook group we do a live video on
there where we invite people to ask
questions and here are some of the
questions from there so first from Ryan
Daniel Joseph hey Ryan
do you need a lot of money to do rent to
rent no technically I rent to rent is a
little money down strategy so it's for
somebody that doesn't really have a lot
of money to invest in property so a few
tips to keep it really low for you a
couple of tips number one use a deposit
scheme yeah other than paying a deposit
which means you really got to pay about
one week's rent it's one week rent yeah
but you don't get that back it's not
it's not taking up deposit number to
rent the furniture if you're gonna if
unique we'll find one that's furnished
actually matter if you can't find one
that's furnished then rent the rent the
photo rather than buying it and rule
number three negotiate and well he
either you couldn't negotiate no deposit
so if the property needs a little bit of
walked into like a little bit of a
refresh and use that as negotiation
skills so say look out
paint the house which you can do for
very cheaply maybe three four hundred
pounds if you do it yourself I'll paint
the house if you can give me like no
deposit or a month's rent
I've managed to go straight one draft
poor nothing now yeah everyone I've done
I've never put deposit obviously you
can't Oxford was no deposit no and six
weeks as long as you've got a contract
you don't need you know you don't need
to draw the contract Oh No so you don't
even need to pay sister fee so yes be
pay so you can do it for pretty much
free next question is from Charlie wait
Li can you explain the pros and cons of
interest-only versus capital repayment
mortgages so pros and cons of interest
only first couple of depreciation well
okay big pro of capital repayments
you're buying the property yeah you're
paying some of the capital off capital
or however nearly all minor interest
only and the reason for that is I'd
rather use the cash to buy another
property rather than paying off the
mortgage and on the one so I don't know
many property investors that buy with
capital repayment most of them that I
know of they use interest only so
interest only obviously you only pay an
interest on the mortgage payments you're
not actually paying any the capital of
the property off but we're sort of
banking on the property increasing in
value over time or you saving up a bit
of money to pay the capital off when it
when it's due obviously capital
repayment you're paying capital off the
mortgage so you are paying down that
mortgage it depends on what you want be
a long term goals
I do interest only you do interest only
Simon does interest only so that's what
we do okay you know but we also remember
where we live which of course seems to
cause controversy everywhere we go you
know that does that creator of every
issue last week next a lot of echo in
that room guys
is there it was that from Joshua Joshua
voice Joshua
although someone else maybe there is one
to you Nick I mean you're watching it
live so I'm guessing
is echoing sorry guys apology guys just
imagine you're driving through the
tunnels in the the the Swedish shouts
and you're on your way to nice skiing
trip and you're listening to us move on
I will quickly hey guys I saw the
podcast and the banter you guys give
what are your top tips to get agents to
know like and trust you and how often
should you touch base with an agent
thanks in advance from Ethan Clayton can
I do that because I deal with a lot of
stay agents is that right yeah so know I
can trust
II think Lee and have you been to one of
the events that I see that because I say
that a lot from stage you got to get
people to know like and trust you if you
want to do business with them and by
doing that you just literally you have
to be a nice guy or lady you have to
turn up on time do what you say you're
gonna do and be just do everything right
so instead of just calling an estate
agent up and bombard and I'm on the
forum with the same questions they get
every single day from every single other
person that rings them make the effort
and go to your chosen area and go in and
see them
actually have or try and have a
face-to-face meeting with them you'll
get a lot farther than then falling them
up now the phone up strategy does work
we teach that and we do we do advise
that but when you've got your defined
area actually get your feet on the
ground get out there and get meeting
agents and if you have a viewing for
instance and you have a viewing at 9
o'clock what time you gonna turn up I
ask that question what time you gonna
turn up I always tell it's a court bust
now I know like no no believe me honest
they believe me they're mad people that
booked appointments and don't turn up on
time how many times do we have a
meetings booked with people that are
coming into office and they don't turn
up on time yeah they gave it a point
being is look if you see you've got to
do something do it the estate agents
time is just as important as yours so if
you say you're gonna be someone time be
there on time mm-hmm Joey Peters
have you ever covered SSAS on the
podcast before and is it something you
would do it's forgotten pensions it's
not something we've covered so we can
perhaps do a little bit research into it
and perhaps cover that in a later date
but it's not something we've covered in
a minute but it's regarding using your
pension to
best to buy investment properties so we
don't want to go too into that in a
minute but we will cover a later date
brilliant well guys thanks ever so much
for watching the show I hope you enjoyed
it we are back next Saturday at 7 p.m.
so please do tune in you can hear us on
Spotify you're gonna have us an Apple
iTunes you can watch us on YouTube and
we will see you next week
see you guys
[Music]
[Applause]